こんにちは　はじめしゃちょーです
なんかな
PDRさんとリベルタスが
動画で
氷に
氷今ここに50kg分あるんですけどね
氷に塩をかけるとなんか
化学反応して熱くなっちゃうらしいんですよ
あっ、危ないのでマネしないでね
あいつらはなんかこう手になちょっとだけお塩を塗ってさ
氷をトゥトゥトゥって置いてさ
熱い熱いって
甘いよ
ま、結局ここには50kgくらいあるわけでな
ま、なんか僕は全身でできるっしょみたいなフリをされたんで全身でやりましょう
火傷したら・・・
危ないね
はいどうもどうもどうもー
はいというわけで早速ね
ここに氷　追加で結構増やしたんですけど
もうバンバン入れてって
とりあえず氷の風呂を作ろうと思います
あ、やべ
よしよしよし
あ、もーー冷た
一応、氷の風呂はできたんですけど
冷たいね
こっからお塩をぶっかけます
多分、浴槽はね塩じゃ壊れないんだよ
薄めればなんとかなるって書いてあったんで多分なんとかなります
なんでお塩入れると痛くなるんかね
うわぁ色々とやばい
南極みたい
はいというわけで完成したんですけど
なんかバキバキいってます
じゃあ行きま..行きますもう
べちゃくちゃ言ってるより行こう
え！？
あっ
あ、あ、あーやばい
痛い痛い痛い
やばいやばいやばいやばい
ちょ待て待て待て
ダメだ
ダメだこれは
何？
なんか体が全体的に凍ったんだけど
あ、ダメだ
ダメだこれダメだ
ダメだダメだ痛い痛い痛い
痛ッ！
いたいたいたい
See you next time
あ、やばいやばい
これ全部実は氷なんすよ
ほら
ここら辺も全部実は凍ってます
なんかよくわかんないんですけど　体が全身的に凍って
やめときましょう